Canadian Prime Minister and Disney
princess Justin Trudeau Justin Trudeau
will be a good step I'd like to talk to
him while we're on the topic of Canada
that's right I mean look at that guy
that guy gets so much poutine I feel
like he has that light and that shine in
his eyes that can do great thing if this
were the old days when alliances was
filled by Kings taking multiple while
Canada would be the world's greatest
superpower this is acknowledged that
very pretty
he's very very pretty
[Applause]
you can feel it justin theroux got my
back it's been such an exciting visit me
to come visit your Parliament while
Prime Minister Trudeau how are you in
good to be saying that again
where's the Stanley Cup right now
[Applause]
I'm sorry it's been in my hometown with
the Chicago Black Hawk I mean it's hard
to make fun of them I do have a photo of
them on my desktop dress is a pirate
that's pretty much all I've got the
finest wool Veta currently I hope the
people we talk less about my hair and
more about the great plans we have for
growing the Canadian economy and have to
and yet here we are
[Music]